so I thought we'd do a sort of rather
long video on a short Topic in that we'd
have a look at compression
um we've done some videos in the past
Dave railsworth's done some on bits of
it Huffman encoding as a w Mike's done
some on JPEG but I thought we'd just do
a sort of General overview about
compression
well okay the best place to start is to
actually think about what we're trying
to solve think about the problem we're
trying to solve we're going to start off
with some data and I shall represent
this over here with a file so we've got
some data and we're wanting to send it
so we've got a copy of the data
or storing a copy of the data somewhere
else
so we've got the date here and we want
to send it somewhere else let's talk
about sending it we may just be storing
on a disk so it takes up less space but
we'll talk about sending it just to keep
it simple and what we want to do when
we're compressing it is take it and
we're going to run it through a black
box which we'll call the compressor
and I'm just going to write compress
because I've drawn the box too small and
compressor wouldn't fit in and that's
going to give us a series of bits ones
and zeros that represent that data and
the aim is is the number of bits here is
less than the number of bits we started
with so that this is going to be smaller
than this and then we can take that
through a decompressor and for
orthogonality I should write decompress
here
and then that will convert it back into
the original data
so that's what we're aiming to do with
compression we're trying to take some
data and represent it as a smaller
amount of data less bits now immediately
there's two things that will strike from
that one we're not going to be able to
represent every file here in less bits
we can prove that mathematically if if
this if we had eight bits here
representing this data that means is 2
to the eight possible combinations 256.
if we're going to store it in less bits
that means this must be seven bits I'm
just going to say this but is it fewer
bits
your name is not Dave brailles just
checking yeah it should be fair you know
so we've got two to the eight
combinations here that means it's 256
possible things here if this is in fewer
or less bits then we must have seven six
five four three two one or potentially
zero but then we won't be able to
distinguish it so we can cross that one
out bits here this is 256.
this is going to be 128 128 this will be
64. that's 192. that'll be 32 that's
224. that's 16 that's 240. I hope you're
checking my math speakers that's now 248
so if we add all them up we end up with
actually if we're using fewer bits then
it's only 254 possible things that we
can represent using fewer bits so we can
prove that we're not going to be able to
compress everything down to being
something smaller there's going to be
some things which will compress to
things that are being bigger at which
point it's not worth compressing it so
we can ignore that what we're aiming to
do is design a system where
most of the data we actually care about
will become smaller because there are
some things for example if we're
compressing a text file we could
probably generate a text file that would
compress to be bigger so it gets expands
rather than compresses when we run it
through the compression algorithm but it
would probably be a pathological case
that wouldn't actually represent any
real text so we wouldn't probably be
worried about it but you cannot generate
a compression algorithm that compressed
that can compress everything it's just
not possible and we can prove that very
easily as we just did actually you can
Define randomness as being an
uncompressible stream
um so that's the first thing uh the
second thing is if we're going to be
compressing things we're going to be
taking information out and so that means
that there needs to be some redundancy
in the original data there needs to be
something in there that we can throw
away without losing the information
that's in there we can throw something
away here when we represent it in the
compressed stream and then we can
recreate it here so there's something in
here which is represented that actually
we can represent in a different way and
still recreate it the other interesting
thing is that often when you look at
compression algorithms so if you look at
something like MPEG or h.264
they will Define
this part of it they'll Define the bit
stream and they'll Define the
decompressor
they're not interested in how the
compressor works
because you can change and this is
particularly important for lossy um
compression things we can class compress
it into two types lossless compressors
the bits we put in are the bits we get
out one for one zero for zero everything
we put in we get out in exactly the same
order with elastic compression algorithm
we get something that's similar
but it's not necessarily identical
um think of it like a photocopier you
put some kind of photocopy you photocopy
it looks identical but you might get the
odd bit of noise that's slightly
different exactly the same thing we can
get the meaning across and get the
information across but we don't get
exactly the same bits and that's fine
for certain things images video sound
but for other things computer code we
definitely want to compress it so we get
exactly the same bits across the
afternoon side are you doing a loss you
want or a lossless one we'll concentrate
on lossless mainly
um today we'll talk a bit about lossy
but generally if you're doing losses
you're making decisions which throw more
information away that you can't recreate
but actually wasn't describing something
in the original data that was that
important an example of that background
behind me is nicely out of focus it's
still moving around because the walls
and computer science do that Sean's
actually on a tripod but it's all the
walls and background that are waving
around in this place but it's nicely out
of focus so actually there's less
information there and if we throw some
of it away
it's it's redundant it's not actually
encoding anything because it's already
blurred and we wouldn't miss it but we
regenerate the original thing in most
cases if you're really editing this and
you're producing things and you're going
to be pressing a lot then the errors
that are introduced with lossly
compression can build up and you perhaps
you want to not do that and keep the
data but certainly for transmitting it
over YouTube then we can let it sort of
be similar but not exactly the same you
won't notice it because you're looking
at me rather than the background which
is really really odd I'd be looking at
the background and not at me but then
each of their own so what we're trying
to do is take the data let's go back to
what we're talking about and compress it
down to a smaller number of bits and as
we said we could perhaps think about
this these compressed bits as being
instructions for the decompressor on how
to recreate the data that we've got
so how do we go about doing this well
one thing that helps to think about this
is actually to break it down into two
stages get rid of that
velocity compression throw it away and
it's gone when we think about data we're
actually thinking about two things we
have
a model
for that data how we describe it and we
also have
an
encoding
for that data how do we encode that
into bits now let's think about that in
an easy way let's think about some text
so I've got
Bananagrams here which one is hopefully
brought in other text-based games are
available London 2012 edition which I
think we got cheap because it was after
2012. there's one on the floor here I've
got an s
we've got a blank there we go space
um
we've got any others let's see if we can
find there we are any Star Trek fans in
the room will recognize that immediately
and so that's our model that we're going
to represent the text as a series of
characters and then they will represent
them one after the other in the way that
we'd write the words
okay so that's our model series of
characters one after the other if we
wanted a blank we could pop that
afterwards we'd have that and then we
could perhaps have another word that
follows it
um there we are
s u n Go for the name of a computer
there we are and so on so that's how
we'd write that Trill space sum we'd
build that up and we could build
everything up afterwards so that's our
model for the day today we've got a
series of characters and they're
represented one follows another to build
up the data
now we could then represent that with an
encoding and the classic one that we use
here is ASCII or utf-8 or Unicode to do
that and with that you take each
character
we'll use ASCII and we'll represent them
with a number so the T that will become
84.
VR will become 82 if I can count
backwards I I've got the ASCII set up on
the computer
so we can represent that as a series of
8-bit numbers and then we can convert
them into binary the bit eight bits so
we've got how many counts we've got one
two three four five six seven eight nine
nine times eight that's 72 different
um numbers so we've got 72 bits so this
would take up 72
bits there we are but how could we
compress it well if you can watch the
video that Dave did on Huffman encoding
or else they're W encoding you could
take into account the fact that some of
these letters are more likely to occur
in English than others so what we can do
is use the fact that these letters occur
in the English text at different
frequencies so T is the second most
common letter to occur in English text E
being the most common so we can say well
actually because this is going to be
more common rather than using eight bits
to represent it we'll use two or three
bits and because you I think no because
which one was it um yeah because you in
this is going to be the least common we
might use eight bits or maybe even nine
or ten bits to represent that the
model's the same but we've changed the
encoding and we would use less bits to
do that so that's what I aim to do by
encoding the ones that occur more
frequently with less bits and the ones
that occur less frequency with more bits
even though we perhaps take up more bits
to represent than we would on their own
we take up less space overall so the
file gets smaller but we do trade
something off because
the encoding we have here is nice for
programs to work with we know each
character is going to be one byte long
if it's asking if you get to ugfa it's
not quite the same but on ASCII there is
one by long so each character we can
sort of skip ahead to the next one or to
the third one very easily as soon as we
start spinning up to variable length
with different numbers of bits we have
to process it in order and effectively
what you're going to do is convert it
back to the normal encoding to ASCII
encoding so that we can use it so we can
change the encoding to make the files
smaller but that's not the only thing we
can do we can also change the model we
use to describe the data and we talked
about that briefly earlier when we
talked about how the background is out
of focus here and that's how jpeg work
which Mike's done a video in that rather
than representing the image of a series
of pixels we represent the image as the
frequencies that make up those series of
pixels and because if you do that and
you read it out in the right order and
watch Mike's video on that you actually
find that most images which are like
this there'll be some areas a bit of my
face and the hair in where you are using
lots of high frequency data to represent
the hair and so on but the background
which is all blurred because Sean's got
a nice depth of field on his camera is
blurred so there's no high frequency
content so by switching it from just the
amplitude of each pixel which is what
we'd normally use into the frequency
domain
we can throw away data in the background
because it's not actually there and
store the data in the foreground where
it is actually there and we end up with
a smaller file now on the way to that
the model we would use here to represent
that file is actually gets bigger so
when we move from the sort of pixel
domain that we've used to to the
frequency domain we end up having to use
10 12 bits 16 bits to represent those
frequencies
but then when we can cross it encode it
using an encoding system we end up with
something that ends up smaller so we
sort of change the model which may be
counterintuitive and make things
slightly bigger for a bit but it means
that the way we're representing the data
means it's easier to not have to encode
that redundancy we talked about earlier
and so when you're designing a
compression algorithm you both need to
think about well how am I going to
encode the bits but also
how am I going to model the data and
that even applies for something as
simple as text one of the easiest ways
that you can gain some compression and
we can see this if we had a sequence of
characters that looked a bit like this
people probably guess exactly where
we're going with this already so if we
had a string like this
pathological example then one of the
easiest ways we can press this is
actually to say well actually we've got
one two three four five six A's
a followed by one two three four five
e rather than taking up 11 characters we
now only take up four or four bytes
um you probably want to represent it
slightly different but if we change the
model and to actually say last time
we're going to describe it not as
AAA but we're going to describe the
number of letters we've got Okay so
we've got six A's followed by five E's
it takes up less space then we can
encode that
is this a model change is it an encoding
change interesting question it can get
blurred which one you're actually doing
at so we'll ignore that before now the
problem with this of course if you've
got something like Trill Sun that we had
before you end up with ill it's one t
one r one I two L one space One S one U
One n it gets massively bigger this sort
of encoding what's commonly referred to
as room length encoding sort of way of
describing data works when you've got a
lot of ice long runs it was brilliantly
for sort of images where you've got
pixels are all the same something like
PNG you can use this quite well but for
something like text where things change
every character pretty much it doesn't
work
that well
um
but there are ways you can get around it
so perhaps one way you could vary this
is say
well actually you can exploit the fact
that if you know how the decompressor
works and you describe and you define
the compressor and the decompressor to
work in similar ways you could for
example say well what I'll do is I will
say if I've seen three A's
the next symbol that comes along tells
me how many more there are so in this
case I would send it as a a a
one two three and then there's three
more and then I'll send it as e-e-e and
two more so we've now got one two three
four five six seven eight which is
better than the 11 we had before but for
something like Trill Sun that would
actually still get sent as nine
characters and we don't need to actually
send any information because we Define
the decompressor and the compressor to
work in the same way of course if we end
up with
ume
then what you end up with is it being
encoded as aaa0
eee08a0 which is now instead of it being
nine characters it would end up as 12
characters so it's got bigger again so
there's always
oh well swings and roundabouts with this
thing
how much room it's got left so now the
sender knows if I don't want to
overwhelm that computer
I'm only going to send he got slightly
dimmer when we got to visco and then
slightly brighter again when we got to
this row and we might find that but
basically if you've got a savings